today i want to going to talk about the
mythical man month it's written by a guy
called fred brooks who's part of the ibm
new york team in the i guess he must
have started in the 50s moving on into
the 60s and this was the era of ibm
wanting to step beyond
architectures that absolutely needed to
be programming assembler they wanted
a paradigm shift in writing operating
systems although they still ended up
using assembler for that
they wanted higher level languages they
wanted a big leap forward and the 360
series did give us several big leaps
forward there is no question about it
the mythical man month is a myth because
unless you are very very lucky and it
only happens occasionally
men and months are not interchangeable
now since it was
first written getting on for 45 years
ago now in 1975 i'm afraid
there's no chance of getting it called a
person month or anything like that so i
am only following the actuality and i'm
afraid that some of the graphs i draw
will have men versus months but if you
want to put personal power down there
absolutely fine the era
that you've got to project yourself back
into which is a lot easier for me than
for many of you is the 1960s and there
was
a really awkward situation that the
basics of computer hardware at least
were understood ibm computers solve in
minutes problems that once took weeks
months even years and what was
understood was that having more memory
cost a lot of money in a previous video
i pointed out and two ibm salesman came
buttoned up
holding that one megabyte of ibm memory
for the 360 series which came as a meg
in a box for demonstration purposes but
could be supplied in a more chassis
mountable format later that one megabyte
would have cost you 100 000
now fred was the leader of the team that
had not only got to specify the hardware
was it going to be six bit characters
how much maximum memory could you have
and all that they not only were going to
specif by the hardware
they were also going to try and move on
from that to writing an operating system
because they realized that this was
classic 60s situation
even ibm customers won't be able to
afford to buy let alone air condition
one of these mainframes per programmer
it's going to be a big shared machine so
we're going to have to give value for
money and make sure that it's got a good
multi-user multitasking operating system
and there's another major task that has
to be taken on turn of 1950 to 1960 is
not very long after genuinely first
generation machines
were
gradually getting
how should we say outdated
and
think back ed sac 1949 one i'm familiar
with
it used basically the bordeaux code it
was five bits
two to the power five is 32. that's not
too bad you say until you reflect that
for your data you want alphabetics 26
and you want numerics 10
that's 36 slots gone already how do you
get over it well you have what's called
a shift character this is still here on
keyboards or simulated keyboards we use
today all of this was a known factor and
the pressure then on all architects was
shall we make a tentative step forward
how about going for six bits
and in
i should say group discussions within
icl within boroughs within every other
ibm competitors
oh an extra bit oh that's going to cost
a fortune will our customers
pay for that because you know adding
that onto every single location oh it
doesn't bear thinking about yes i think
we if if we price it carefully we can
get away with six bits
and certainly
again some of you may remember i think i
referred to this earlier when i came to
nottingham we were stuck with a six bits
per character computer the icl 1900
series it had
six bit characters and you could pack
four of them into a word which might be
able to hold a biggish integer
although 24 bits isn't very big
so to get even bigger
agglomerations you had to
as it were
electronically link two of these
together by the time you got to 48-bit
words you were getting
to a stage that at least you could do
single precision arithmetic
almost accurately enough to keep her
engineer happy if you look up as i have
had to do the details about fred by the
way he's aged in his early 90s
and for those of you who are going to
make sarcastic comments in the comments
no i haven't met him i'd love to meet
him i really would it would be uh you
know a great treat and a great privilege
but fred a leader of the team who had
been on earlier ibm 6-bit
machines
not going to have the power and
penetration of this new plan series he
said no no no no really six bits is not
enough
um
okay
you could do the alphabet but you can't
do the alphabet in upper and lower case
which is what we want we increasingly
want to be able to typeset stuff so we
need to be able to distinguish between
lowercase g and uppercase g
and they really ought to have codes of
their own and when you tot it up numbers
uppercase lowercase some punctuation 2
to the 6 64 it's not quite big enough
obviously
all hardware people know it's
unthinkable to have a hardware
bite
that is actually an odd number of bits
that way does madness lie but
we
have got to be brave here let's go for
the eight-bit bite and of course a bite
meant in those days any agglomeration of
bits that your machine deemed to be
worthy of holding a character
and i could just imagine
fred you know have you gone completely
off your rocker you know have you any
idea how much this will cost and i think
that my retort would have been well look
they're ibm customers and they know
they're getting the best this this isn't
any a memory this is ibm memory and in a
way i can see that if anybody was going
to pioneer and do this it had better be
ibm
because they had customers that could
afford
to be alpha testers on this idea for
them and to report back whether it was a
good idea or not to shorten the story
somewhat they did go for the 8-bit bytes
but also what came along with that and i
don't know again if it was
somebody else on the team or whether it
was fred or whatever
also came up with the idea of as follows
there'll be a temptation
to put in
or make possible an agglomeration of
four of these eight bit entities that's
32 bits that will hold a very decent
size integer indeed because on a 6-bit
machine
digging out each 6-bit character from a
24-bit agglomeration oh it makes me sure
to think about it you needed bit shift
operators you needed to shift left the
six bits on the left into a vacant word
as it was 24-bit word and then shift
them back again and throw away the other
stuff or do whatever and somebody on
that ibm team said no
we make the bites be addressable had i
been the chief hardware man and i've
probably had 50 fits because you are
making the address bus be that much
wider yeah
you're basically saying no it's not you
know
i'm not pointing at one big thing i'm
pointing at lots of smaller things
individually however of course fred
would say yes but once you've landed on
that thing and don't forget a lot of our
programmers and a lot of our customers
use cobol
and we if we make our characters be
eight bits then all our character-based
programming on which
from which our bread and butter comes is
immediately
probably an order of magnitude faster
almost than it would be on lesser
machines because we've got the eight bit
addressable bite so anyway he won the
day and i think the
the rest is history because looking up
his biography now
um
was amused around at the bottoms when
people said fred what are you most proud
of
what was your biggest contribution to
system 360 architecture and he didn't
say making people aware of the mythical
man moment he said no
winning the battle that we didn't need a
six-bit bite we needed an 8-bit bite and
i was so glad to see that down there in
black and white in a way the thing we're
going to talk about for the latter part
of this talk now
he would have regarded i guess it's a
very nice
desirable side effect he decided in the
1970s
to write an account
of how we did it on the 360. but in a
chatty accessible kind of
storytelling almost kind of mode
and right at the start and in various
places in this book do make sure you get
the 1995
20 years after version because it's got
not only the original reproduced but
it's also got an analysis of where i
went wrong says fred brooks why did he
make his name with that and what was it
all about i have here
a chart
he plots out a task which is typically
reckoned to be nine man months of labor
and he said okay let's accept that see
what it means nine man months
what this means is
that if i put one person on that task it
will indeed take them nine months
if i put two persons on that task then
of course it'll halve the time won't it
it'll only take four and a half months
if i put three people on it it'll take
one third of the time it'll take three
man months and so on and so on until the
limit point comes that if i can only
afford nine programmers to put onto this
task it will all be done in one month
stop he says that is an idealized
situation almost never realized in
practice because it assumes that your
nine people do not have
a need to communicate with each other
that these tasks are truly separable and
in parallel a bit like picking tomatoes
or strawberries or something like that
you have your own patch you don't bump
into anybody else you can pick
independently of all the other pickers
in the vegetable field something like
that and he said this very very rarely
happens it just isn't like that
the situations in the lair below you in
the hardware
where you can get genuine parallelism
like that like fetching bits in parallel
since those bits are on separate wires
and don't interfere then yes this sort
of argument but when it's real people
who need to consult then it goes more
like this
first he said let's take a look at the
absolute polar opposite of everything
being separated and everybody can do
their own thing i do believe that this
thing that is now on my left i think
it's a rectangular hyperbola because the
product of the x and the y numbers
yields a constant number as it were nine
times one is nine three times three is
nine and so on he then points out he
said your worst nightmare
is
to take on nine people
in order to get a nine-fold increase you
hope but unfortunately your underlying
task is not
fully and independently partitionable
it's one of these horrid things where
the person who does a little bit at the
beginning
and says oh that's my month now i want
my money has to hand over the state of
his calculation to the next person at
all and you say well why can't the
person hand it over earlier no no if
it's one of these awful problems where
you have to compute a magic number to be
handed on to the next stage you can't
hand it on until you've computed it so
it's pointless hiring nine folks up
front you're just gonna have to pay them
furlough money while they sit there
twiddling their thumbs because they
haven't had the kickstart that their
particular contribution so it's like a
you know a passing on of a token in a
real area if if you've got a problem
that really is like that it's innately
cereal from start to finish then you are
in deep trouble you can pour men and
money and material into it until you're
blue in the face you won't get it below
nine months worst possible case
but then he said it's never quite that
bad often
let's go to intermediate possibilities
on the next sheet now as you might
imagine all that does is it takes our
previous perfect rectangular hyperbola
shifts it up a bit and you can see here
the net result is pretty much what you
expect you
try adding
men as fast as you can but it levels off
higher
than
being down here which is the genuine
asymptote where it's headed for the axis
it doesn't do that and that's because
there's inherent
enough inherent serial communication
there to shove the curve up a bit and
you can't do any better than that
so that would be the case for if you
like an average
program that a team might write with
some
intra-team communication
if you get unlucky
and you get a task
that has got more complex communication
you've still got time up here you still
get men along here but can you see
what's happening now
that
little curve i've drawn there is trying
to get more and more like a flat
straight line at the top
you remember
the diagram before last
there's still enough parallelism in
there that it doesn't quite flatten
itself out into a straight line but you
can see what happens
you get some improvement and then you
get none at all and you just head up
towards the inevitable it's nine man
months whether you like it or not
so
task with complex intercommunications
can have a curve looking something like
that
and what he said was you really must
bear this in mind all the time it's no
use talking about
men and months as if they're
interchangeable and trade offable
they're not one of the things i thought
when i saw this is then there's the
other thing that you've got to have the
handover right yes that's right this
person has to explain what's going on to
the second person that's exactly right
sean and i think he more or less in in
different words says that this is
another thing about adding manpower to a
project particularly late on you spent
so much time explaining to the newcomers
who are quite talented just why this
intricate structure was necessary before
they could even start any programming
that you'd have been better off not to
take them on at all
and so there are various homilies in
here which say if you think you are
underpowered on a project try and
realize it early you can probably rescue
the situation with more men and whatever
if you recognize it early enough and
take drastic action but don't leave it
until it's one month away from delivery
time and then have a panic and saying oh
my god there's a year's work to go
you know um memorable phrase number two
how
did this project get to be a year late
says the big boss and the answer is
one day at a time
they're all sending their data as well
so now what we've got
is a situation that wasn't handled by
this concept of flow control what we're
now going to need
to demonstrate this in a second
is that some methods log4j is like milk
it's like water it's everywhere